[Music]
Android 1.6 enables applications to be
rendered properly on different display
resolutions and densities developers can
also specify the types of screens
supported by the applications Android
1.6 includes support for CDMA in the
telephony stack support for new screen
sizes and CDMA means Android can run on
even more devices and networks quick
search box allows users to search the
web and their phone directly from the
home screen it provides suggested
results from the web even while the user
is still typing quick search box
provides relevant contextual information
like local business listings as
suggestions without having even to
launch the browser users can also find
answers to common queries with quick
search box for example local weather
users can search for information managed
by applications like contacts but they
can also take actions such as call Adams
mobile users control how quick search
box works on their phone for example
they can select what types of content is
included in their searches the search
framework provides developers a way to
easily expose relevant content from
their applications here's an app for
letting users track what books they have
read the developer made the apps
searchable from the quick search box by
author name and provided suggestions
Android 1.6 includes a text-to-speech
API this API uses a multilingual speech
synthesis engine that allows
applications to speak text strings with
the right accent the initial set of
supported languages is available to
users from Android Market
kissed you in Android Market we're
making it even easier for users to find
great apps from developers the latest
version of market improves overall
discoverability users can quickly choose
among apps games and downloads in the
category view they can explore the top
paid top free and titles that just came
in and with each app or game users can
now see screenshots submitted by
developers as well as read the reviews
from other users to learn more about the
Android 1.6 release visit
developer.android.com